بالتزامن مع انشقاق الطيار السوري العقيد
حسن مرعي الحماده ولجوئه بطائرته الى
الاردن اعلن اربعه ضباط اخرين اثنان منهم
برتبه عميد واثنان برتبه عقيد اعلنوا
انشقاقهم عن الجيش النظامي السوري
وانضمامهم الى الجيش السوري
الحر
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسين ما هي دلاله انشقاق قيادات عسكريه
بهذا المستوى وما هي العوامل التي ادت الى
زياده وتيره الانشقاقات مؤخرا وكيف ستنعكس
هذه الانشقاقات في صفوف الجيش الرسمي على
تماسك نظام الاسد في الفتره
[موسيقى]
المقبله خمسه ضباط اقلهم برتبه عقيد
اعلنوا في يوم واحد انشقاقهم عن الجيش
النظامي السوري رفضا كما قالوا لقتل شعبهم
على مذبح نظام الاسد الذي حصد حتى الان ما
يزيد عن 15000 سوري منذ اندلاع الثوره ضده
منتصف مارس من عام
2011 نزيف الضباط والجنود السوريين لم
يبدا الان بالطبع والجيش السوري الحر الذي
يمثل الضباط والجنود المشاققون غالبيته
العظمى خير شاهد على ذلك لكن ان يقدم ضابط
طيار على الانشقاق على متن مقاتلته فهذا
هو التطور النوعي في هذه
العمليه ما اقدم عليه العقي السوري الذي
هبط بطائرته في قاعده الملك حسين الجويه
اعاد طرح موضوع التناقضات الداخليه في
الجيش النظامي الى واجهه الاحداث الحادث
سبقه حديث اخر عن تدهور الحاله النفسيه
لكثير من الضباط والمجندين الذين وضعوا في
مواجهه مباشره مع شعبهم انه فيما يبدو
اوان ارتداد سياسه النظام بضرب الشعب
بالجيش واللعب على وتر التنوع في تركيبه
المجتمع السوري حتى داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
وهي السياسه التي انتهجه النظام السوري
بهدف تكريس خيار التازيم داخليا ومحاوله
نقل لهيبها الى خارج الحدود السوريه بيد
ان انشقاق الطيار حسن الحماده وهروبه
بطائرته الى الاردن ليس حدثا معزولا في
التوقيت او السياق فقد تزامن مع انشقاق
مجموعه من القيادات الميدانيه العسكريه
قوامها ضابطان برتبه عميد واخران برتبه
عقيد اعلنوا انشقاقهم على نظام الاسد بسبب
ما قالوا انه غلو النظام في مواجهه شعبه
فهل هو دليل اخر على تراخ قبضه النظام على
المؤسسه العسكريه قد يكون الجواب على هذا
السؤال سابقا لاوانه لكن الاكيد ان هذه
التطورات تشير الى اقتراب ان لم تكن بدايه
مرحله جديده في ثوره السوريين ضد نظامهم
فمع تزايد اعداد الضحايا المدنيين بصوره
لافته وعلى وقع التصعيد المضطرد في ممارسه
العنف ضد المواطنين يجد الكثير من منتسب
العسكريه السوريه بكل عناوينها انفسهم في
مواجهه تناقضات لا يمكن احتمالها بين
عقيدتهم العسكريه من ناحيه وتوجيه اسلحتهم
الى نحور مواطنيهم كما يريد النظام من
الناحيه الاخرى واقع تزيد من حدته تصرفات
من قبيل ما قامت به قياده الجيش في وقت
سابق عندما عجزت فرق النخبه واجهزه الامن
عن السيطره على الاوضاع فلجات الى تفعيل
دور جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه مما ادى
الى استخدام العنف بشكل مفرط وادى الى
توسيع رفعه الانشقاقات بين الضباط
المحايدين الذين لم يسلموا ايضا من حمله
القتل والاعتقال
والتعذيب انها اذا سياسه العنف تصل
نهايتها فترتد بنتائجها الكارثيه في نحور
اصحابها ولان بدت الدائره الضيقه للنظام
متماسكه حتى الان فان وصول الانشقاقات الى
قيادات ميدانيه مهمه في الجيش السوري يؤشر
الى ان هذا التماسك قد لا يستمر
طويلا وينضم الينا من القاهره الدكتور
محمد مجاهد الزياد نائب رئيس المركز
القومي لدراسات الشرق الاوسط ايضا ينضم
الينا من الحدود السوريه التركيه النقيب
المظلي عمار الواوي امين سر الجيش السوري
الحر وقائد لواء التحريري فيه وانضم الينا
من حمص عبر الهاتف العقيد الطيار في الجيش
السوري الحر قاسم سعد الدين قائد المجلس
العسكري في حمص في ريفها سيد سعد الدين
هلا قربت لنا سيناريو انشقاق هذا التيار
واطلب لجوئه في
الاردن ع سؤق اسالك عن السيناريو المحتمل
الذي جرت فيه جرى فيه انشقاق هذا الطيار
ولجوئه الى
الاردن السلام عليكم ورحمه الله طبعا نحن
نبارك عمليه هذه الانشقاق لعقيد الطيار
البطل حسن مي حماده الذي انشق بطائرته ميج
21 من مطار خلخل العسكري وتوجه الى
مطار مطار في الاردن الم
مطار تكون الاخيره باذن الله وهناك تنسيق
عالي لاخوه الضبا وفي بعض في فصل كبير من
الطيارين السوريين الان في السجون
السوريه
هل هنالك تتوقع بانه سينضم اليه
المزيد نعم سيدتي نعم سوف يظم هناك مزيد
والان النظام يلفظ انفص الاخيره وينتظر ط
الرحمه طيب اسالك انا
عن بدات سؤالي لك عن الطريقه التي ينشقون
فيها ان كان ممكنا ان تقرب لنا الصوره
يعني امنيا كيف يستطيعون
في يعني الضابط الاخير هذا انشق بمقاتلي
وهذا تطور مهم جدا هل لك ان تشرح لنا اكثر
لوجستيا كيف يتم
ذلك سيدتي سيدتي عم نحكي عن الهاتف لن
اسمع سؤالي سالتك عن الطريقه التي يمكن
الانشقاق بها على متن المقاتله
نفسها للاسف لا اسمعك جيدا انما
انا الو س ساعود اليك فورا
يعني ان يعود الينا الصوت معك دكتور محمد
مجاهد الزيات نائب رئيس المركز القومي
لدراسات الشرق الاوسط هل يمكن
اعتبار انشقاق التيار هذا اليوم تطورا
نوعيا يؤثر بشكل ايجابي على حال الثوار في
سوريا يعني هو اي انشقاق هذا التيار يبقى
حدثا فرديا حتى الان يعني ليست مجموعه
خرجت او انفصلت عن النظام لكن مجرد انه
خرج ضابط او تيار برتبه عقيد فان هذا
الحدث يحمل عدد من الدلالات الهامه التي
من اولها انه لا يصل الى رتبه عقيد طيار
يعني راجل لا يتولى عملياتي ضابط عمليات
بالدرجه الاولى الا موثوق به او داخل جزء
من النظام فعندما ينشق ضابط برتبه عقيد
وطيار ويخرج بطائرته ف هذا الحدث له دلاله
كبيره النقطه الثانيه ان النخبه التي لها
وزن لدى النظام هي القوات الجويه ومعها
المخابرات الجويه التي هي اقوى اجهزه
المخابرات السوريه والاكثر ثقه واكثر
امانا بالنسبه للنظام فعندما يخرج ضابط
برتبه عقيد ويهرب دون ان تتمكن المخابرات
الجويه من من معرفه مثل هذه الامور فهذا
يدل على اختراك كبير وعلى ضعف من هذا
الجهاز وعلى مغامره كبيره من هذا الضابط
يعني هذا الحدث له دلاله كبيره هل يمكن ان
يغري اخرين نعم لكن يمكن ايضا ان يؤدي الى
قلق من النظام والتركيز على منع الطيارين
من ركوب طائراتهم او فرض مزيد من
الاجراءات الانضباطيه وهو ما يشغل النظام
بصوره كبيره خلال الفتره
القادمه النقيب المظلي عمار الواوي ايضا
احول لك نفس السؤال عن الى اي حد يمكن ان
يشجع هذا الطيار اليوم بقيه الطيارين
بالنظر الى اهميه صفوف هذا اللواء في
الامن
السوري اسمحي لي ان اترحم على شهداء
الحريه والكرامه واللعنه على كتائب الاسد
المنهاره المتقه قره والنصر المؤزر لشعبنا
العظيم بثورته ال ثوره العزه والكرامه
انسه الجيش السوري الحر هو قبضه الشعب
الحديديه والذراع الطويله لهذا الشعب
العريق هذه الذراع التي ستضيق الموت وهم
وراء جدر سلاح الجو السوري هو الورقه
الاخيره في يد نظام القتل والاجرام وقد
قام هذا البطل بشق عصى الطاعه على
الجلادين وانحاز ل الثوره واعلن عصيان
الاوامر وان كان الاول
بطائرته ولكنه هناك ضباط كثر طيارين
انشقوا امثال العقيد الركن البطل الطيار
قاسم سعد الدين وهناك انشقاقات كثيره حدثت
في معظم المطارات اسمحي لي ان اذكر بعض
الانشقاقات هناك العقيد الطيار المدرب
حميدي الحميدي نائب قائد سرب البعث 525 في
مطار مرجه سلطان معتقل منذ ثلاثه اشهر وتم
ضربه واهانته واعتقاله امام جميع عناصره
وامام المطار ايضا الملازم اول انس غزيل
تم اعتقاله في 10/9 201011 في حلب من قبل
المخابرات الجويه بنفس الم المطار هناك
اعتقالات ايضا لضباط وصف ضباط بينهم
الرقيب اول فادي المصري بتهمه محاوله
الانشقاق ايضا مطار ضمير تم تصفيه اكثر من
23 ضابط طيار بالشهر السابع 2011 بتهمه
محاوله الانشقاق مطار بلي هو مطار حوامات
125 تم اعتقال 22 ضابط بتهمه محاوله قصف
وكر القصر الجمهوري ل الطاغيه بشار الاسد
ايضا هناك انشقاقات في مطار المزه وحدثت
تصفيات في مطار المزه وايضا مطار التي فور
الذي انشق منه ايضا العقيم سعد الديني سيد
الواوي اريد ان استوضح منك كانت هنالك
انباء منذ حواله الشهر بان الجيش السوري
الحر هدد بتصفيه من لا ينشق هل كان ذلك
صحيح وهل تعمد الى هذا
الاسلوب انستي الجيش السوري الحر هو ابن
هذا الشعب وكل من يقف الى جانب الث هو ابن
هذه الشعب كائنا من كان نحن قلنا
ودعونا العناصر الشرفاء من مختلف الطوائف
والعقائد بالانضمام الى ثوره العزه
والكرامه وعدم قتل ابناء هذا الشعب نحن لم
نقل كل من لن يقف او لم ينشق سنقوم
بتصفيته نحن قلنا ندافع عن الشعب
وسنقتصر هذا الشعب السوري المطالب بالحريه
والعداله والكرامه هذا ما قاله الجي
السوري الحر وهذا ما يطالب به قاده الي
السوري الحر وقاده الكتائب في عمليه نقوم
بها على الحواجز التي تق بالقصف العشوائي
على القرى والمدن الامنه نلب منهم بشكل
دائم الانشقاق قبل البد بالقصف على هذه
الحواجز لذلك ما يشع منبل
النظام هناك تصفيات من الجيش السوري الحر
لكل من لم ينشق هذا الكلام غير صحيح ابدا
واريد ان اقول للذين قالوا سابقا من اعلام
العهر عهر النظام الذي قال ان الملائكه
تنشق والجيش السوري لا ينشق ها هو الان
الجيش وعصابات بشار الاسد تتاكل وتنهار
وتنحاز جميعها الى صفوف ثوره العزه
والكرامه عقيد طيار في الجيش السوري الحر
قاسم سعد الدين ارجو ان تكون تسمعنا الان
بشكل واضح اريد ان اسالك عن تاثير هذه
الدعوات وتلبيه البعض لهذه الدعوات
بالانشقاق على بقيه نفوس الذين
مازالوا يقاتلون مع الجيش النظامي هل لديك
معلومات عن
ذلك سيدتي بالنسبه للا شقاقات سوف تتزايد
باذن الله ونحن في
محددين موعد ان شاء
الله كبيره جدا ونحن ننصح المترددين من
اختنا الضباط ان ينالوا الشرف الانضمام
للجيش الحر و وما يكونوا عارض المستقبل
على على اطفالهم واولادهم انه بقوا مع مع
هذه العصابات القاتله وانا ابشر انا سؤالك
لن اسمعه جيدا ابشر الشعب السوري بذ الله
اي طيار حربي من يذهب على اي منطقه الا
يخصف القطل الجمهوري ويذهب الى الى الاردن
او الى اي دوله ديقه باذن الله تعالى انا
لا اسمعك بوضوح و اعتقد ان المشاهدين ايضا
لا يسمعونك بشكل واضح سيد العقيد الطيار
في الجيش السوري الحر قاسم سعد الدين
حدثنا من حمس شكرا جزيلا لك على اي حال
ومما استطعت ان افهمه منك بان هنالك
انشقاقات اخرى تنتظرون ان تحصل في سوريا
على غرار هذا الطيار الذي طلب اللجوء
السياسي في الاردن اليوم بعد الفاصل
سنناقش الى اي حد ستؤثر الانشقاقات
المطرده في صفوف الجيش السوري على مستقبل
النظام في الفتره المقبله اذا نناقش ذلك
بعد فاصل قصير فابقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي
تتناولوا اثر ودلالات تزايد الانشقاقات في
الجيش السوري في ضوء انشقاق خمسه ضباط
بينهم طيار لجا بطائرته الى الاردن دكتور
زياد كيف تشرح لنا نفسيه الجندي الذي يضطر
في النهايه الى توجيه اسلحته
وبندقيتين كان اقسم اليمين على حمايته كيف
تصف لي هنا الصراع النفسي الذي
ينتابه يعني انا في اعتقادي انه الجندي او
الضابط اللي بيكلف بضرب المواطنين
المدنيين
العزل بيواجه ازمه نفسيه حاده لانه بيرى
فيه اهله
وجيرانه بصوره اساسيه وبالتالي فطول مده
واجهه ما بين العناصر او الجنود والمدنيين
او طول انتشارهم داخل المدن اعتقد انه
بيؤدي الى اثار سلبيه عكسيه تساعد في
النهايه على رفض الاوامر وعصيانها ولكن
يبقى الخطر يبقى ضعيفا امام هل يستطيع ان
ينجو بنفسه لو عصى الاوامر وخرج هل تتاح
له فرصه او يفتح له الابواب للانضمام
للمعارضه دون مخاطر تتعرض لها اهله هل
هناك النظام بيقوم بالضغط على الافراد
فينقل من محافظات الى محافظات اخرى لكن
بالتاكيد هي بترسب في اعماقه رفضا للنظام
ولممارسة
ربما تتراخى او ربما تضعف
برايك
انستي عظا عصابات بشار الاسد ونظامه انهار
وتاكل بشكل كامل في كل يوم يسقط عشرات
القتلى من من عصابه بشار الاسد وهناك
عشرات الانشقاقات من مختلف الرتب ايضا
هناك وزاره الداخليه لا تنسى انسه وزاره
الداخليه التي يقول عنها حفظ النظام هناك
اكثر من 100 ضابط من وزاره الداخليه بينهم
برتب عميد وما دون انشق ووقفوا الى جانب
هذه الثوره وزاره الداخليه ايضا منهاره
ومتاكلش والقضاء المدني هناك
انشقاقات كبرى وقفوا الى جانب هذه الثوره
انشقاقات في مختلف دوائر الدوله سواء
الاساتذه والاطباء وكل اكثر من 65% انشقوا
لذلك اسمح لي ان اقول كلمه فقط فقط ملاحظه
انت تقول متاكل منهار ولكن الارقام في
بنيه الاجهزه الامنيه والجيش النظامي
السوري لا تدل او لا تثبت كلامك هذا
التيار هو الاول الذي لجا بطائراته الماج
21 هنالك 125 طائره اخرى من هذا النوع هذه
الطائره الاولى منذ اكثر من عام على
اندلاع هذه الثوره هناك
365 طائره قتاليه لم نشهد اي انشقاق
منها يا انستي انا انا كنت في في معظم
العمليات وال اقسم انني رايت العناصر رايت
عصابات بشار الاسد تقوم بتكبيل العناصر
داخل العربات النظام يعرف ان هؤلاء
العناصر سينش قون ويقفون لذلك يقوم بتكميل
داخل هذه العربات النظام منهار لذلك بدا
بشراء بدا بشراء مرتزقه من روسيا وايران و
وحتى من الافارقه كما فعل قبله الطاغيه
معمر القذافي انت لا تعلمين الصف الاول هم
من من الجنود صحيح ولكن الصف الثاني
والثالث هم من من المرتزقه والقتله الذي
جلبهم هذا النظام من مختلف الدول هذا
النظام ي يعتمد على نظام القتل الممنهج من
لا من لا يقتل يقتل لذلك لذلك انت لا
تعلمين بما يحدث داخل هذ داخل هذا النظام
من انشقاقات كبرى ايه دكتور الزياد هل
توافق النقيب رايه بان هنالك كثير من
المرتزقه ومن المهددين ايضا لذلك قد لا
تبدو الانشقاقات كبيره ومهمه ام النظام
يلعب على تركيبه معينه داخل الجيش وتركيبه
تنوع المجتمع ينعكس ايضا من الناحيه
الطائفيه ايضا في داخل الجيش
نفسه اولا انا لا اتفق مع ما ذكره سيد
النقيب عن حول نقطتين اساسيتين ان هناك
مرتزقه لم يثبت مثل هذا الكلام النقطه
الثانيه انه يتحدث كما ان النظام قد انهار
فعلا وفي تقديري ان النظام لا يزال يستعصي
على السقوط بسبب بسيط انه تركيبه المؤسسه
العسكريه منصهره هي والمؤسسه الامنيه في
الحزب وفي الطائفه وبالتالي هناك ما زال
هناك نوع من التماسك لان كل السقوط اي
النظام يعني سقوط الاربعه وبالتالي النظام
يراهن على نوع من التماسك موجود لا تزال
تاتي اليه الاسلحه من روسيا لا يزال الجيش
الحر سوريا الحر مع كل التقدير عباره عن
مجموعات لكن لا يوجد هيكل تنظيمي واحد
يمارس عمليات هو يمارس عمليه الكر والفر
معه الحديث عن هار وزاره الداخليه لم يحدث
بعد الطائره التي خرجت ليس لان الضابط او
اليار الذي عربها او لجا بها للخارج كيف
تفسر استمرار هذا التماسك كما تصفه مع
العلم ان هنالك فضاع ترتكب ي اي انسان
يمكن ان يكون لديه ذره ضمير يمكن ان يصدم
وان يبتعد وينشق بالاضافه الى تهديدات
والكلام عن انكم ستلاحق امام المحاكم
الجنائيه واخر واحد تحدث في هذا الموضوع
السفير الامريكي في
دمشق نعم نعم انا لا لا اوافق على ما يقوم
به النظام لكنني اصف ما يعني ا احاول ان
اقيم موقف النظام كما هو
الان شدتك انه هناك اطلب تفسير لهذا الوصف
يعني هناك انصهار ما اه الانصهار القائم
ما بين المؤسسه يعني هناك الضباط الذين
يحصلون على درجه على رتبه اركان حرب او
ضابط ركن كان يشترط ان يكون حزبيا اذ لم
وطائفيا في نفس الوقت وبالتالي فالقياه
الكبرى المحسوبه التي تتولى المناصب
الرئيسيه كلها محسوبه على النظام وتعرف ان
سقوط النظام يعني سقوطها فتحتاج الى فتره
للاطمئنان للخروج منه النظام مازال حتى
الان يفرض سطوه على القيادات حتى لا تخرج
من من دائرته وتعتبر ان سقوط النظام يعني
سقوطها ايضا مازال النظام متماسك ما زال
الجيش الحر يحقق مكاسب لكنها ما زالت غير
مهدده بدرجه استراتيجيه النظام حتى الان
سيد النقيب رد عليك الدكتور هنالك من
يعتبر من الجيش القيادات من الصف الاول ت
تعتبر ان سقوط النظام تعني سقوطها
بالاضافه الى تواتر الانباء التي تقول ان
الثوار قد يلجؤون الى عمليات انتقام منهم
وبالتالي يتمترسون خلف هذا الموقف مع
النظام ما
رايك يبدو ان ضيفك انستي يتابع دائما
اخبار النظام على قناه ال قناه الدنيا
وغيرها من القنوات انستي عندما انشقت
الضباط كانوا يقولون لا يوجد هناك رتب
كبرى الان اؤكد لك ان هناك اكثر من من 50
ضابط برتبه عميد من لم تلوث يده بدم الشعب
السوري ولم يقاتل بذلك هناك ضباط كثر نحن
ننسق معهم داخل داخل هذه العصابات
المتاكله وزاره الداخليه لدينا اسماء
واعداد كبرى انشقت ووقفت الى جانب هذه
الثوره انسه
كل الارياف في جميع سوريا هي خارج نطاق
سيطره النظام وهذه الارياف كانت تملك
مدراء نواحي ومدراء مناطق وضباط
شرطه لذلك هم جميعا الان في داخل هذه
الثوره ويخوضون حربا ضد عصابات بشار الاسد
القاصر وال الطاغيه لذلك يا انستي لس من
العدل ان تقول الدكتور انه يتابع يتابع
معلوماته من من وسائل اعلام رسميه سوريه
هنالك ارقام كما ذكرت لك كعدد الطائرات
التي لم تنشق وهنالك
ايضا حتى هذه الارياف التي ذكرتها هذه
مناطق صحيح انها خارجه عن سيطره النظام
السوري حاليا ولكن فيها الكثير من الدماء
ودفعت ثمن كبيرا وفيها كثير من الفوضه
وعدم الامان
ايضا لا لا انستي ال الارياف وقفت الضباط
والعناصر وقفوا الى جانب الثوره نحن لم
نخسر دماء في هذه المناطق نحن نسقنا معهم
سواء كانت وزاره الداخليه او ايضا في
عصابات بشار الاسد هناك تنسيق مع معظم هذه
العصابات المنهاره هناك ضباط شرفاء وعناصر
شرفاء في كل يوم هناك انشقاقات قناتكم
الكريمه لا تظهر معظم الانشقاقات تظهر
الرتبه الكبرى هناك اعداد كثيره من
العناصر وقفت الى جانب هذه الثوره في كل
يوم اكثر من 50 عنصر يقف الى جانب هذا
النظا هذه الثوره بعدته وعتاده وصلتت
فكرتك سيدنا نقيب المظلي عمار الواوي
وايضا اشكر الدكتور محمد مجهد الزيات نائب
رئيس المركز القومي لدراسات الشرق الاوسط
حدثنا من القاهره شكرا جزيلا لكما وشكرا
لكم مشاهدينا بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه